[Music]
[Music]
new york
there's no other city like it in the
world
it's a city of contrasts and endless
variety
embracing all races all cultures all
creeds
on the streets and in the canyons of a
thousand different neighborhoods
a city of sound and movement
new york is an incredible mix of people
of promise
and problems
you know too often in our cities we
become so caught up
in the daily rush of living that we are
never really aware
of all those thousands of people
who touch our lives each day
new york can be a lonely place when
you're old
or handicapped
when you're sick or alone and unable to
reach out for help and as life grows
more impersonal and complex
our need for person-to-person health
becomes even more compelling
we need to be tended when we're ill
to be comforted when we're alone
to be helped when we can't help
ourselves
sometimes what we need most is to reach
out and touch someone but no matter how
large or complex the city may be
there are always some very special
people
willing to devote their skills
to giving that kind of help people like
the visiting nurse
who brings comfort and health and caring
to every new york home
home to a new yorker can be an apartment
in the south bronx
the pad in the village a brownstone
gramaci park a row house in queens
or a single room in an old west side
hotel
the visiting nurse is familiar with
every section of the city
it is here that you'll find her helping
people cope with illness and the
problems of daily life teaching people
how to live with their handicaps in
order to survive
reaching out into every neighborhood
nursing
counseling
helping the new mother
the poor
the disabled
the elderly
the drug addicted
the visiting nurse service is the
largest non-profit public health nursing
agency in america
it's a multi-service agency
providing a wide range of vitally needed
comprehensive care
but the problems of providing home
health care are mounting
in new york as well as throughout the
united states the population is
increasing
we are living longer
and we are becoming more aware of
people's needs
and no one is more concerned with this
problem than the executive director of
visiting nurse service of new york mrs
eva m reese we're seeing in new york
city the same kinds of problems that i
think exist
all across the country perhaps we see
more of them because we're a larger city
and ours is a large agency
but unless
home health services across the country
develop a range of services that can
really be meaningful to people
in getting their health needs met
outside of institutions
the whole country is going to be in in
very serious trouble
hospitals throughout america know the
problems of their communities
and new york has 130 community hospitals
one of these is columbia presbyterian
located in the washington heights
section of new york city where last year
their vanderbilt clinic had over 400 000
outpatient visits this community around
us of some 300 000 people in the last
few years the physician population has
dropped from over 200 physicians down to
less than 50 physicians
and i might say in a community in which
it would appear that the medical needs
have increased director of vanderbilt
clinic dr joseph snyder we've been
doing our very level best to take care
of all of the people and so far as
possible but there's just too many of
them out there with just too many
difficult needs
that we just can't take care of everyone
and we need help we need all the help we
can get we here in the clinic need to
have that arm out in the community i
have no hesitation in saying that we
could not take care of as many patients
as we do if we did not have the services
of visiting nurse
the visiting nurse is the source of a
great deal of comfort and a great deal
of strength for the patient and a great
deal of peace of mind for the physician
the difficult task of providing home
health care every day for thousands of
new yorkers is a demanding and often
frustrating job requiring extreme
dedication
but it's the kind of challenge visiting
nurse service of new york has been
facing daily for over 80 years
i was just gonna say it looks great
today much better
this long history of service to the
city's people began when new york was
the teeming gateway to america for
millions of immigrants
many of whom settled in the crowded
tenements of the lower east side
it was here in a house on henry street
that lillian wald a young nurse
founded what is today
visiting nurse service of new york
inspired by her courage and dedication
thousands of nurses have followed in her
footsteps
alleviating the pain and suffering of
hundreds of thousands of men women and
children
times have changed and neighborhoods
have changed
but the human needs of people remain the
same today field staff members of
visiting nurse service make more than
400 000 visits a year to people in need
of care
their visits take them into the city's
most disadvantaged slums to middle-class
neighborhoods and into the wealthiest
sections
for visiting nurse service of new york
is for everyone whoever they may be
young or old
married or single
whether or not they can afford to pay
wherever the visiting nurse goes she
must be resourceful enough to handle a
variety of problems
in the home she confronts loneliness
poverty and poor nutrition
and a big part of her job is helping
people to organize their lives teaching
them how to help themselves as well as
each other
carol brown visits six or seven patients
a day she helps to rehabilitate the
handicapped teaches diet and nutrition
and works with doctors to carry out an
effective plan of care
her caseload runs the gamut from
geriatric patients to the young man or
woman living alone broke a leg and a
skiing accident
or the instruction of a new mother in
the care of her baby
the hospital people come to you stripped
of essentially everything they are
except for being a patient they're not
in their own environment they're in your
environment
and in the home this is where they live
this is how they live sit down honey how
are you feeling
i will talk to myself here this is them
and i think it's real and i like it
straightening up and things like that
and i'm not able to shop because when i
was going
me and this big shopping cart i guess
that was too much
at a time when families are scattered
and neighborhoods are changing
a visiting nurse like rene vasalo is
more than a nurse
[Music]
feels like the daughter who lives
halfway across the continent
the neighbor who moved away
she is a
friend before you sounded very full yeah
i was coming up the stairs
oh
and i was you know i'm a little in are
you taking it easy yeah i think it's
very easy very slow okay very easy very
slow whenever i
gotta be slow because i haven't got to
strain yet okay
mr troll
hi how are you doing how are you today
oh i'm not too bad
are you having any trouble with you
breathing well when i walk the stairs as
you know i don't know why any coughing
you know so otherwise no coughing but i
once in a while like you know are you
bringing anything up on your course yeah
a little bit
there's nothing uh
just white flames and things like that
if there's any changes
you know if you find that you're having
more trouble breathing or that you're
coughing more let me know how to contact
the last time you went back into the
hospital when that happened
yeah yeah i don't think it will but just
i hope not i hope not well so far so
good i said
god wasn't in me i had that
wonderful hopeful name from the doctor
had a good doctor
so far i'm on my feet that i can say
nine months
on my feet and i can't do little things
not much but
go around you know every day a little
bit
every day a little bit and
timeless passes the week have you gotten
any tingling or pain
the visiting nurse becomes involved in
the lives of people in a way that few
professionals can
as you know
she plays many roles
one of the most important and most
rewarding is that a family substitute
it's good
oh let's hope so okay i have my chef and
everything so i'm praying to god that
comes something then
okay
um should i come back friday to see you
all right it's the trail you missed the
blow you can't see it's fine okay
any time
well when you make the strudel i'll
definitely come back well you need me or
not at that point i'm coming back not
this week yet i have to walk too far to
the apache this is mrs colony from the
visiting nerve service
yes
geraldine colony starts her day as all
visiting nurses do
in a local district center what about
your medications
[Music]
i think being a visiting nurse you can
offer them more of yourself more care
more of your attention more of your
professional abilities and therefore
they do receive more they receive much
more on a very individualistic level all
right whenever you're ready i'm ready
i'm ready now all right
okay just stand there for a second
the visiting nurse is often the only
person bringing hope and happiness to
the lives she touches
sometimes their only contact with the
outside world
this holds particularly true with many
geriatric cases
but she also plays an important part in
providing proper care for a new life
[Music]
each year thousands of expectant mothers
and new mothers receive instruction and
guidance in the care of their infants
during visits to the home nurses like
sarah lepin are trained to observe and
evaluate any physical emotional or
social problems that may affect patient
care
in the majority of cases she is equipped
to handle such problems
well many times there are social
problems that uh the parents are trying
to deal with
and this is when you turn to your social
worker
and asked him to make a visit to find
out what's going on to see if we can be
of help in this area whether it's
housing whether it's
dealing with different city agencies
but this our social worker takes care of
or tries to
often a patient's pressing health
problems are intertwined with social and
economic circumstances
when you go
i spoke with a lawyer from legal aid
and together with the other
professionals of visiting their service
he works to ease the physical and
they're not going to be recouping that
money from your child the emotional and
the environmental conditions that affect
people's lives bringing them the
resources to help them get through
difficult times
to meet the needs of the community
visiting nurse service has broadened the
range and scope of health care adding to
its staff specialists in physical
therapy rehabilitation and speech
therapy
specialists in mental health and
nutrition
and the family nurse practitioner who
has special training in physical
assessment and management of patient
care
she is a valuable link in the visiting
nurse program of cooperation with
hospitals
ministering to patients after they are
discharged visiting nurse service of new
york recognizes that home health care is
only part of the solution to the
increasing health needs of its community
they are also reaching out to the
walking sick
and the walking worried too in centrally
located places like the one at the
george washington bridge bus terminal
under the guidance of a dedicated board
of directors special committees and
volunteers
they have established a program of
reaching out to people in a variety of
settings
bringing help and aid to clubs for
troubled youths
shelters for homeless men
schools for unwed pregnant girls
drug addiction centers
and single room occupancy hotels
with a couple of peaches
at the very heart of the visiting nurse
service is a philosophy of true concern
for the needs and problems of people
whoever or wherever they may be
a strong desire to reach out and help on
a personal one-to-one basis
it's hard work
demanding and sometimes frustrating
[Music]
but not without its rewards and personal
satisfaction which can be found every
day in the eyes of thousands of grateful
patients
it's a service that requires people who
are not only trained in their profession
but have a concern and compassion for
their fellow man
truly a special breed
highly motivated to help in every way
they can like nurse olga perez
the reason i primarily went in was to
teach the mother how to take care of the
little girl with the spica cast and to
perhaps show her some ways since this
limits the little girls movements to
show her some ways in which she didn't
have to be so limited you're trying to
teach people how to stay well to give
them preventive care which is the kind
of information that they need to be in
the home to be independent it wasn't
easy because there were just so many
other problems i mean this wasn't the
only thing you come into the house there
was no furniture the apartment was sadly
in need of repairs the mother pregnant
and then there was a little boy who had
club feet and there was the other child
who had pneumonia which kept reoccurring
so it was like from one thing to another
she was she could spend the whole week
just making clinic appointments never
mind trying to manage a home with
very active little children the mother
was warm and and caring and it was like
the kind of home you walk in you say oh
they deserve everything and you wish you
could do everything for them
nurses like olga perez
sarah lepine
geraldine fellaini
[Music]
and carol brown
are just a few of the great many
concerned people who comprise visiting
nurse service of new york
it is through the efforts of visiting
nurse service of new york and agencies
like theirs that the importance of home
health care is being recognized
throughout america
but the ability to provide the broadest
range of home health care requires
volunteers public contributions medical
science and social services
all working together to help meet the
needs of our society
in a hectic world we are often lost in
the preoccupation of earning a living
making a life
and the dedication and devotion of the
visiting nurse to the needs of others is
a lesson to us all
we never know until it strikes home
how illness or handicap
can change the life
our lives we never know when we
ourselves may need the helping hands of
others
through its inspiring program of service
to people
the visiting nurse service of new york
reaches out and touches us all
in time of need
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you